[Música]
al menos 29 personas han perdido la vida
a causa de los tornados y tormentas que
han golpeado unos siete estados de
Estados Unidos las autoridades empiezan
a evaluar los daños materiales que
incluyen miles de hogares sin
electricidad
fuerte polémica en Ecuador tras el
anuncio del presidente Guillermo lasso
de autorizar la tenencia y porte de
armas de uso civil para defensa personal
organizaciones destacan que la medida de
transfiere a los ciudadanos la
responsabilidad Estatal de seguridad y
protección
se cumplieron 41 años desde que inició
la Guerra de las malvinas y Argentina
renovó su reclamo de soberanía sobre
este territorio al recordar a los
soldados caídos y a los veteranos Que en
1982 se enfrentaron con Reino Unido por
ese archipiélago
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarnos iniciamos en
Estados Unidos porque las poblaciones de
siete estados del país empezaron a
evaluar las afectaciones provocadas por
una serie de tornados y tormentas que
causaron graves daños materiales y la
muerte de al menos 29 personas dejando a
miles de hogares sin electricidad el
estado de Texas se encuentra en alerta
máxima por la posible llegada de un
fenómeno similar veamos el informe de
Andrés triviño
destrucción y caos es el balance que
deja el paso de al menos 50 violentos
tornados y poderosas tormentas en siete
estados en el sur y medio oeste de
Estados Unidos donde casas negocios
árboles y autos Fueron arrasados por la
magnitud del evento Aunque este tipo de
fenómenos es difícil de predecir una
alerta temprana que salvó cientos de
vidas como la de esta familia en el
estado de Tennessee hicimos que los
niños se metieran en la bañera porque se
supone que es el lugar más seguro todos
nos encogimos porque las puertas Se
abrieron de golpe las puertas del frente
y todos los cristales de las ventanas
todo explotó al mismo tiempo al menos
unos 650.000 hogares se quedaron sin
electricidad durante el fin de semana en
los estados de Arkansas Indiana Illinois
Mississippi Alabama Tennessee y Delaware
en diciembre de 2021 unas 80 personas
perdieron la vida después de que otra
serie de tornados azotaran el estado de
Kentucky y hace tan solo una semana un
tornado arrasó Misisipi matando a 25
personas y causando enormes daños
materiales por lo que el presidente Joe
biden visitó el sitio y se comprometió a
que el Gobierno Federal se hará cargo
del 100% de los gastos de reconstrucción
en un intento por ayudar a las
comunidades más afectadas a recuperarse
cuanto antes
el viento comenzó a levantarse y a
levantarse y a levantarse y a levantarse
podía sentirlo toda la casa temblaba
entre tanto el estado de Texas se
encuentra en alerta máxima ante la
posible llegada de un fenómeno similar
común durante el inicio de la primavera
la presidentada de llegó a Belice este
domingo en la última escala de su gira
por Centroamérica la mandataria asiática
aterrizó en el aeropuerto de Belmopán
proveniente de Guatemala donde en su
tercer día de visita participó en la
provincia de Chimaltenango en la
inauguración de un polémico hospital
construido con fondos taiwaneses y cuyas
responsables son sindicados de
corrupción
cambiamos de tema porque en Ecuador hay
una fuerte controversia luego de que el
presidente Guillermo lazo anunciara lo
que aseguró son nuevas medidas para
combatir el aumento de la violencia en
el país principalmente a raíz del
narcotráfico con las nuevas
disposiciones a partir de ahora los
mayores de 25 años podrán portar armas
legalmente para su defensa personal
como una manera de combatir la violencia
el presidente de Ecuador anunció tres
medidas urgentes para hacer frente al
imparable aumento de la delincuencia el
narcotráfico y el crimen organizado en
el país una de las que más sorprendió
fue la autorización de la tenencia y
porte de armas para la población civil
se autoriza la tenencia y porte de armas
de uso civil para defensa personal de
acuerdo con los requisitos de ley y el
reglamento soy inocente este anuncio se
da en medio de la crisis política que
enfrenta el mandatario y el asombro que
produjo la noticia sobre el
fallecimiento del empresario Rubén
charrés uno de los Implicados En el
presunto caso de corrupción por el que
el presidente Guillermo lasso será
llevado a juicio político dentro de los
requisitos para aportar armas se
encuentra tener al menos 25 años de edad
obtener certificados psicológicos y
toxicológicos no tener antecedentes
judiciales entre otros también se
autorizó el uso de aerosoles de gas
pimienta pero se prohibió la fabricación
artesanal de armas plazo anunció las
nuevas medidas tras hechos violentos
registrados Durante los últimos días
como el abandono de una cabeza humana el
asalto a un banco en Guayaquil y el
secuestro de un hombre que
posteriormente fue encontrado con un
artefacto explosivo a su cuerpo además
de los numerosos casos de asesinatos y
extorsiones
ocupante la situación que vive el
Ecuador tiene es bastante preocupante
porque la violencia escalado a niveles
inimaginables tenemos o contamos
diariamente con asesinatos con robos con
extorsiones a negocios dentro de las
medidas también se encuentran controles
y registros informáticos y un estado de
excepción con toque de queda en la
provincia costera de guayas y las
provincias de Santa Elena y los ríos
además de un apoyo de seguridad privada
para la Policía Nacional
ilegal es uno de los días de
subsistencia de los colombianos
residentes en el bajo cauca en el sur
occidente del país allí las autoridades
llevan a cabo una guerra contra la
extracción de oro argumentando que este
proceso financia grupos criminales los
mineros lo niegan
le llaman los dragones dorados son
enormes máquinas que tragan los ríos
colombianos en busca de oro
según las autoridades la minería ilegal
financia grupos del crimen organizado
algo que contradicen sus operadores son
Mineros de la zona donde llevan años
haciendo la actividad
que no se le esconden a nadie la presión
de las fuerzas de seguridad del gobierno
contra este tipo de actividad hizo que
cientos de Mineros protagonizaran
manifestaciones y bloqueos de carreteras
a principios de marzo que nosotros
estamos dispuestos una formalización
estamos siendo muy estigmatizados hemos
tenido mucha presencia militar con que
corremos mucho riesgo que nos vayan a
quemar la draga o que nos capturan Lo
cierto es que la minería mueve la
economía de la zona donde opera por lo
que la guerra contra la búsqueda de oro
afecta a los residentes locales de la
minería Nosotros siempre acá todo lo que
vendemos son a ellos a los mineros viene
acá los compran el pescado la yuca leen
la tienda a veces los compran las cosas
todo lo compran acá el mayor problema de
la minería ilegal es la contaminación
del medio ambiente en el proceso para
sacar oro las dragas desvían fondos
aluviales y contaminan las aguas de los
ríos con mercurio un componente
necesario para separar el miner de las
rocas el 65% de la producción de oro en
los ríos colombianos es ilegal según
datos de la oficina contra el delito y
la droga de la ONU Argentina conmemora
el aniversario número 41 del inicio de
la guerra que enfrentó a esta nación
austral con Reino Unido por el
archipiélago de las malvinas en 1982 en
esta jornada Argentina renovó su reclamo
de soberanía al tiempo que recordó a los
soldados caídos y veteranos de la guerra
en un acto en Buenos Aires el presidente
Alberto Fernández dijo que la lucha no
ha terminado y recuperarán sus Islas por
vía pacífica desde el año 2000 el 2 de
abril Argentina conmemora el día del
veterano y la veterana y de los caídos
en la guerra de las malvinas
fortalezcamos más que nunca nuestro
compromiso con malvinas más que nunca
digamos las malvinas fueron son y serán
Argentina
tuvo y no ha terminado y vamos a
recuperar nuestras Islas por la vía
pacífica y vamos a seguir elevando
nuestra voz Hasta que el mundo nos
escuche finalizamos en la ciudad
boliviana de la paz con un festín de
colores y Sabores para celebrar la
diversidad gastronómica de la amazonía
de este país y de Perú
maíz de todos los colores
agiguzanillo y pescados autóctonos un
festín de colores y aromas para celebrar
la diversidad gastronómica de la
amazonia peruana y boliviana los chefs
marciata y Virgilio Martínez combinaron
sus talentos para trasladar la
biodiversidad de esta región a los
platos de un prestigioso restaurante de
la ciudad de la paz en Bolivia
latinoamericana muy fuerte no que quiere
preservar su identidad lo que quiere
preservar su cultura ancestral lo que
quiere preservar su cultura es productos
y que quieres este realmente
solo cocinar por por cocinar impresionar
sino querés trascender con lo que haces
para esta colaboración utilizaron la
información recopilada por el proyector
Sabores silvestres de la chef boliviana
que a lo largo de 15 años de
investigación con comunidades indígenas
de la amazonía ha registrado centenares
de ingredientes hemos trabajado con
alrededor de 200 comunidades indígenas
con más de 600 productos registrados y
con los que hemos trabajado también en
el restaurante y bueno para nosotros es
un orgullo Y esto es una celebración No
solamente la amazonía y a la
biodiversidad pero también a nuestros
productores más que un catálogo de
ingredientes nativos y técnicas
culinarias el proyecto Sabores
silvestres también colabora con
productores indígenas así apoyan
económicamente a estas comunidades que
tratan de preservar un ecosistema
excepcional pero gravemente amenazado
fin del informativo gracias por su
sintonía
[Música]